iacono
honoré et benjamin nous raconte
l'histoire de la touraine avec plusieurs
centaines de bénévoles lasemo ferry 2
semble ans et nous transporte de
l'époque gallo romaine jusqu'à la
révolution quelques minutes avant le
spectacle c'est l'effervescence en
poulies ce dernier a justement pour les
combattants c'est tendu on s'habille un
peu tous avant avant la nuit tombée un
petit peu de stress toujours un peu
d'adrénaline avant de rentrer chez sun
on met plusieurs couches de ce temps là
c'est agréable et après on se prépare
pour aller s'amuser parce que pour nous
c'est de l'amusement même si ça reste
professionnel derniers préparatifs aussi
pour la quarantaine de cavaliers de la
scéno féerie avant le show les chevaux
sont scellées et échauffé l'originalité
de la cavalerie c'est que ça s'arrête
pas le soir après le après le spectacle
on doit ramener les faut s'en occuper la
semaine ils sont auprès d'un conte fée
déroulement les on les entraîne en essor
constant de cul pour les soignent voyons
faire sa grande soeur zoé maya s'est
aussi prise au jeu j'ai directement
accroché j'ai commencé par traîner dans
les coulisses a pas faire grand-chose et
au final maintenant je fais un peu de
tout et tant que je peux continuer je
continuais au contraire c'est vraiment
génial et je m'éclate toujours autant
tous les ans un esprit de famille qui
rend l'événement attachant chaque année
les mêmes têtes se croisent pour suzanne
ça fait bientôt 15 ans j'ai commencé par
la guinguette en dansant et puis
maintenant je fais la fleuriste et puis
et puis et puis on est toujours prêt à
faire quelque chose qui sont prêtes à
inventer quelque chose c'est ça qui nous
entraîne et qui nous permet une belle
nous garder en forme et ne participait
encore un spectacle féerique à découvrir
tous les week-ends jusqu'à mi août
[Musique]